Ми у Дьялі - передмісті Будапешта.
Місцева влада замінила вуличне освітлення на світлодіодне -
профінансоване на гроші Євросоюзу.
Утім, мешканці незадоволені.
Вони вважають, що освітлення занадто темне.
Крім того, бракує не менше сотні ліхтарів.
Місцева влада не надає взагалі жодної інформації про цей проект.
Наш мер, який належить до урядової партії,
відмовляє нам у будь-якому доступі до документів.
Такі вуличні ліхтарі можна побачити повсюди в Угорщині.
Це мільйонний проект.
І, як підозрюють в Європейському управлінні з питань запобігання зловживанням та шахрайству,
тендер відбувся в кращих традиціях кумівства.
Адже виграв його не будь-хто,
а зять угорського прем'єра Віктора Орбана.
Новинний портал Direkt 36 провів своє розслідування.
Аніта Ворак знає деталі.
Проблема у цій справі в тому, що вимоги у тендері були зманіпульовані таким чином,
що лише зять прем'єра міг перемогти.
Слід знати, що гроші ЄС в Угорщині
розподіляються напряму урядом.
За інформацією Direkt 36,
в рідному місті Віктора Орбана
на будівництво цього футбольного стадіону
також були використані гроші ЄС.
Мільйонами з Брюсселя профінансували навіть будівництво
нікому не потрібної залізниці,
що закінчується в районі лісу.
Зиск від цих будівельних замовлень отримав Льорінц Месарош -
ліворуч  у кадрі - друг молодості Орбана
і мер цього міста.
Частина цих грошей розподіляється між друзями та родичами
прем'єр-міністра і його оточення.
І ми знайшли не один приклад цього.
Незважаючи на численні підозри в корупції,
угорське правосуддя бездіяльне,
нарікають працівники Direkt 36.
Немає ані обвинувачених, ані засуджених.
Угорський уряд не хоче й чути про корупцію і кумівство у власних лавах.
Речник уряду Золтан Ковач каже,
що такі звинувачення - ніщо інше як інтриги опозиції.
Угорська юстиція пройшла випробування.
Ще раніше європейські інституції встановили,
що угорське правосуддя незалежне
і відповідає європейським стандартам.
Угорщина отримує на рік
близько чотирьох мільярдів євро з Брюсселя.
Скільки з них осідають у кишенях оточення Орбана –
невідомо і навряд чи з'ясується.
Адже на майбутніх виборах в Угорщині партії Орбана знову
пророкують перемогу.